um so there's a woman going viral right
now talking about she regretted
divorcing her pastor husband and I
honestly I haven't even seen this yet I
didn't have time to watch it so we'll
see how this went for her let's pull it
up this is not
easy coming out later in life losing the
stability of um an 18-year relationship
that needed to be we needed to I needed
to leave anyways but
the
stability this is scary so if anyone
thinks that like I got my [__] together
I don't I have no idea what I am doing
um and the look she gave
me was like
disgust welcome back family just when I
thought that these modern women might
have run out of reasons to divorce their
husbands this woman just pulled a joker
card on me she was the pastor's wife but
but surprisingly decided to end an
18-year-old marriage just because she
thinks that she is a lesbian now and the
worst part about this story is that she
expected the whole church to endorse her
decision of breaking up her own family
let's jump
in so I just received a really
interesting uh message and um this
person says that my life looks so great
and that he's going to unfollow me
because
I'm practically gloating it wasn't a
criticism and I don't take it that way
but I do Wonder like what videos are you
watching because this is not
easy coming out later in
life to my
family the first person in my family to
come out um coming out to people of
Church Los losing that
Community losing the stability of um an
18year relationship
that needed to be we needed to I needed
to leave anyways but the
stability this is scary so if anyone
thinks that like I got my [__] together
I don't I have no idea what I am
doing so that's my reality
I'm strong and I'm bold and I'm
aggressive and all those things but I'm
also
sensitive I just want to know what she
thought was on the other side like why
would Church accept a gay
woman I mean [__] it's church I think
it's hilarious I mean I I I know I got a
little bit of a swearing problem but I
don't go swearing church do you know
what I mean like what did she fact that
she says you guys think I've got it
together no one thinks you've got it
together no one is seeing that thinking
you've got it together I just want to
know okay cuz this is my thought if
you're going to be practically like on
the verge of
homelessness couldn't you just like like
girls and just deal with it and just
stay like I mean is that I mean I don't
know maybe I'm going crazy but I'm
like is your sexuality like that
important she's she's crying a lot about
something that she's chosen to do right
she she's complaining that she's lost
all of these things and she's saying you
know what I'm tough all of this it's
like okay well this video definitely
doesn't make it look like that but
regardless she's saying all of this and
she's complaining about all the things
she's lost so it's like
well maybe
don't maybe don't
like I don't know maybe the men are
going to come for me in the comments but
it's [__] that
important thing and it was
was probably the hardest interaction
I've had yet for about 8 years I was a
youth pastor at a church and I had a
core group of
about six girls that I would Mentor like
I would go to their sport games and
their concerts and their shows and I was
really just there to encourage them and
build them up and one of my closest
students I I ran into her yesterday and
I was in shock and I just went in like
oh oh my God
hi um and the look she gave
me was like
disgust now I didn't feel shame and so
that's F exciting I didn't feel any
shame but I was sad
afterwards that I realized how much time
I had
invested in people
and that how I they accepted me as a
certain
version I was still Jessie then like I
didn't change I got better [__] yeah I
got
better once
again my Tik Tok
family has just
been
there and I
never I never would have thought that a
social media app
[Music]
would literally like be my
lifeline I never I never would have
thought this guys I'm
so thankful and I've been absent on here
for for good
[Music]
reason I never in a million years would
have thought that this process would be
as difficult as it has been and um yes
I'm vague booking and that's just the
way it's going to have to be for safety
and uh I just I just had
friends guys I've met these people like
once twice a couple
times they're like you can come hang
[Music]
out
I just don't know what I would have done
without this community you guys have
been my lifeline I don't know what she
expected to happen like what you think
they're going to at church they're going
to say wow we're so happy you I actually
I kind of want to go to this church yeah
cuz it sounds
based a church that actually sticks by
traditional church Val that's I thought
I was like 2023 I know that's what I was
like I was like what church is what
church you go
to no okay because I'm like what did she
expect then she's like okay I didn't
feel shame but I felt sad and I'm
like you're you're kind of describing I
would I would love to take This Woman's
phone off of her for a
month I can oh I just it' be really
interesting experiment I think she'd go
back yeah I think she the only reason
that she is has clearly got all these
ideas is she spent way too much time on
Tik Tok or whatever it is she's decided
that she wants to be a martyr among the
Liberals and what's the easiest way to
do that well to to leave your children
and say that you're now pursuing your
sexual Liberation in whatever way shape
or form that may be and yeah she she
apparently doesn't feel any shame I
think let's take her phone away because
the only reason she doesn't feel shame
right now is because she's in this
narcissistic Loop take it away I know
and then let's reassess the situation
yeah I bet yeah you took it away for a
month some people really need a social
media break like I I challenge people
like this to go a week without your
phone just try it you see it in the
lifespans of almost like the like a lot
of influencers that were like they
thought one thing they were more
conservative in their early 20s and you
see them kind of switch when they start
to get like a group like they start to
let like one liberal in the group then
they just start to get then they start
the whole then they divorce their
husbands and it's just like crazy but
that was my thought was I was like it's
almost like better that you know the
patterns and tell them the P like this
is just I'm thinking out loud
spitballing a little bit but I was I was
thinking how I don't think the solution
is hiding people from the world because
the world will come to them that you
can't avoid it yes and it's interesting
cuz in my I feel like my generation and
your generation is like a slight
difference because mine wasn't it was
like half online where you grew up cuz
you're you're 22 23 23 yeah so you grew
up pretty I I would imagine everyone was
on social media yeah so I would say by
sort of year five which is for the
American people like 10 years old uh we
had like Vine come about like my sort of
really funny memories from when I'm like
10 11 is like me and my friends
recreating Vines so it was very
prominent from such a young age and like
think about how young that is 10 years
old and Vine was like everything back
there yeah well and that's is great
though we had yeah Facebook was the big
one for me that Facebook with my
generation is like really not yeah it's
like where you go for like family things
and to see what's going on in the local
area if someone's selling something
maybe but Facebook was always kind of
like an older thing for at least for for
my group people